blah blah blah blah blah Ambika doors  break into places second acting is a  subversive act ticket prices are insane  theater belongs to the masses I'm done  clip I'm just gonna ride it out ideas  clearly not working yeah I just want to  this is our first date date  remember what we talked about Naomi I  guess yeah here I was read remember it  was like the curtain egad were you  former fide I think you were wearing  that black dress the one with the  buttons down the front no you were with  me when I bought that that place when he  sings right we could talk about the only  yeah I said are you sure I'm sure I'm  sure  but you want I could tell I am now I'm  so sure